auf dem mond wachsen die ersten pflanzen
also wenn mond premiere
damit ist den chinesen wirklich ein
kugel um so etwas hat vorher niemand
versucht und den chinesen ist es direkt
gelungen die ersten pflanzen auf dem
mond was wie wo warum das verantworten
wir jetzt alles hierbei klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierende wissenschafts videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasste
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen es
ist ein bisschen tragisch gerade sind
die ersten baumwollsamen auf dem mond
aufgegangen schon werden sie wieder
zerstört
es wird jetzt nämlich ziemlich kalt und
eine lange mond nacht bricht über die
chinesische mondsonde chang'e g4 herein
die pflanze werden bei minus 170 grad
erfriert aber trotzdem mit der mondsonde
chang'e e4 ist etwas bahnbrechendes
gelungen ein baumwollsamen ist
aufgegangen
dafür wurde die luft im gewächshaus der
mondsonde extra mit co2 angereichert
damit die pflanzen besser wachsen können
filter reinigen die luft und uv lampen
sterilisieren sie das aufgehen der sahm
ist ein riesiger erfolg denn es ist sehr
schwierig die bedingungen für wachstum
von pflanzen auf dem mond zu schaffen
das deutsche forschungszentrum für luft-
und raumfahrt dlr fängt deshalb auch
erst mal in der antarktis mit einem
komplett autonom gewächshaus an
dort ist es auch extrem kalt und ihr
gewächshaus ist so konstruiert dass nur
wasser zugeführt werden muss das gibt es
nicht nur in der antarktis sondern auch
auf dem mond am mond südpol gibt es
wasser zudem ist ausreichend sonnenlicht
auch auf der rückseite des mondes dar
dazu kommt bei der emission dass das
ganze auch noch auf der rückseite des
mondes stattfand also auch dort ist der
pflanzenanbau steuerbar als das sind
gute nachrichten für eine permanente
mondstation die versorgung mit selbst
hergestellten lebensmitteln wird so zur
realistischen möglichkeit und der
marsianer markt.de ist keine utopie mehr
der auf dem mars selbst franz lang
gebaut hat um zu überleben unter
optimierten bedingungen kann das auch
auf dem mond möglich sein allerdings
gibt es einen wermutstropfen nur die
baumwollsamen sind aufgegangen
kartoffeln und die samen der
ackerschmalwand haben es nicht geschafft
aber unabhängig davon
dies ist ein erster schritt und die
auswertungen werden zeigen warum wieso
weshalb was geklappt hat
in zukunft verbessert werden muss ein
kleiner schritt für einen menschen und
ein großer nein ein kleiner schritt für
eine pflanze
naja und ein großer für die menschheit
oder so also wer hat das noch mal gesagt
ich sage nur apollo 11 und die
mondlandung genau vor 50 jahren dieses
jahr wir werden dazu etwas ganz
besonderes machen abonniert also
unbedingt unseren whatsapp newsletter
hier
dafür drauf kriegen da halten euch auf
dem laufenden und hier drunter
draufklicken für die story zur landung
der changi vier chinesische mondsonde
chang'e ii 4 auf der rückseite des
mondes gelandet bis dann also drauf
klicken bleibt dran